yeah welcome to this video this will be
with bit different video because um yeah
in the 70 or present an interesting game
and to comentary on this as usual but
this video is also meant to point you to
another interesting chest channel on
YouTube and this is some to the channel
online chess lessons it's a very
interesting channel because it presents
very wide range of from subjects within
chess also features lots of videos
bye-bye Grand Master's um very often
presenting their own games and showing
them yet their insights this is always
very interesting to see player some do
do em comments on their own games so
it's very interesting channel and I'm
wanted to point point um to this and
also present them a game here in this
video by them creator of this channel
and this is USO national master william
stewart on he recently got ya got them
very interesting and win very nice game
against us yeah junior star ray Robson
was rated above 2600 already and team
will manage to win a very nice game I
want to present that though because it
has been done on video quite a number of
times already if you want to watch this
M game you should check out wills
channel online chess lessons he has got
done this game featured of course but
i'll show you another game that that he
played them about two years ago against
an international master in saponin
displaying black here to lowes as the
name is from chile from south america
and yeah let's see um are the game
proceed some will open some one Knight
f3 and it's nine f6 symmetrical answer
and here we see be three so it's some
rather quiet fianchetto opening I myself
quite often play g3 at this point very
often though some openings are only
deceptively quiet they start out quite
but advantage m compared to some other
more sharp looking lines that actually
the pieces are still on the board after
15 moves I'm always amazed that people
think okay you need to play if ought to
get a sharp game well this is just bogus
you can play you for and your opponent
plays the Petrov and after 20 moves
you're sort of falling asleep and this
rarely happens in those he and shadow
openings I mean you can you just delay
the fight for a couple of moves moves
but it will pop up with all the pieces
on the board okay I'm okay on b3 I'm
like of course as a wide radiant
references he just answers b6 and now g3
so we've got this kind of double fee and
shadow opening we should be seven and
Bishop g2 yeah at this point of course
them as some then no pawns in the center
black hood play wide range of moves he
could them stay within complete symmetry
which would be okay also um could just
play ecigs sort of a Queen's Indian
setup and this some because it's very
flexible could lead to different kinds
of positions even ahead shock could
easily arise something like this and
we've got them this typical Hedgehog
kind of position so it's a very flexible
way of opening a game these double fee
and shadow lines but black gum played
something entirely different ta played
'if I've now this is quite interesting I
don't think it's a bad move but one
thing which you always have to keep in
mind
are certain kinds of positional features
sometimes don't work well together and
one of those things that don't work well
together very often is to push the e
porn two squares and have a queen size
fianchetto so the bishop won't be seven
and a pawn on Ani 5pm very often those
kind of this kind of combination has one
drawback and this is the square f5 this
f5 square is very often naturally
covered by the bishop being on c8 so it
would be on c8 it would cover this f5
square and this simply is not the case
of the boo-boos VN shadowed so very
often the Sun is a sensitive square and
it's l square which can easily be used
by night and this night is close to the
king so this M is a very instant problem
that black can needs to face him and the
upcoming moves will see that of course
it is playable but you need to be a
conscious afterwards so what answers d3
I think this is a very sensible move it
looks a bit passive but the issue was
black might play you for if you don't
play d3 yourself so let's say you would
um simply cancel here then black might
consider playing it for something like
this and it looks a bit like a reverse a
lockin on a lock on defense and this
move b3 is a bit superfluous in this
kind of position I mean even c5 could be
a problem as the night doesn't have to
be seized be three square so I think
it's very sensible to to prevent this
advance and go for g3 yeah black now
played t6 you have to at one point cover
this pawn you cannot play this because
just e5 is hanging bit embarrassing so
at one point you need to cover it he
played d6
white now cancelled and yeah here blacks
black play some a move which are
thinkers certainly playable but I know I
don't like it so much he played c5 it's
um a move designed to grab more space in
the center and controlling deform so
white will never get to play deform very
much likely difficult to manage this but
then this whole setup here is all on
dark squares and those light squares are
very sensitive now so you've got them
we've got possible weaknesses on those
squares very often if you want to go for
this setup you need the bishop really
only 62 to cover d5 and this is sort of
a little bit of yeah it's not really an
ammonia setup but it's playable so c5
and white plate be should be to first we
should be a knight be 37 he wants to
keep this diagonal open so he didn't
play knight c6 and now see form grabbing
some some space he on the queenside and
having a look at the d5 square black now
play to win c7 this is um I think again
a move that at first and doesn't make so
much sense at least if you ask me but it
has got an idea one problem in this
position is if like would play g6 which
would be the first move from I would
think about because i would like to
control this this f5 square and in
general the bishop on g7 is just a more
flexible piece than on a seven so the
attention would be Bishop g7 and then
cancels on this problem with this move
has a problem though it's a very
surprising problem
and motif that is well worth remembering
what can play night xe5 year very M
surprising Bishop g2 and then 97 and the
problem is this long diagonal so um yeah
white is just just one material here you
cannot capture here as Bishop f6 with
them all this at the end white has an
extra porn and pretty nice position also
i've got this kind of things also
possibly coming so this is a nice
tactical idea always have to be aware of
technical ideas on the diagonals very
often some surprising things are
possible but this is why black couldn't
play g6 and i thought this move Queen c7
would actually prepare g6 but yeah we'll
see what happens white now place a form
and this is a very interesting decision
and I actually like it a lot white now
blocks the senator completely but then
he simply somewhat better placed in this
symmetrical position at first you would
sing a que it's all blocked and not
nothing much going on but then white has
some advantages he's got the night still
on b1 which is nice because the knight
on c3 is just better placed than the
night on d 7s the c3 night s has got
ideas like this year and also white as
fianchetto already so he's got nine th
for deaf for as ideas also of course
night h4 to f5 so why does somewhat
better in this position it's all very
closed and Blaxland solid but if one
needs to position where only white can
do something really and now black plate
remove a six which I don't really
understand and it's very often the kind
of routine that you can play but I think
you simply had better things to do here
I would think I'm just a g6 would be
better trying to get ahead with
development and then it could but it
could continue something like
it's not age for Bishop g7 and then
possibly f form and this is um this will
get interesting I mean it's very often
like this those quiet openings um tend
to lead to interesting little games here
why tim has good ideas of pushing at 5g
form possibly i'll just keep this
tension in the center it's also very
very interesting to do this like also
can consider to capture and this
position is also um yeah bound to lead
into some interesting Miller game where
white has got this pawn duel but black
hey at least head now has some possibly
find Bishop on g7 so it's an interesting
game um I'm not quite sure black played
86 and the things this just loses a move
93 just continuing yeah and now I'm he
played Bishop e7 which I don't
understand I mean you need to really
play g6 here you cannot allow what's
what's happening next so he just should
have just played g6 and covering the f5
square okay we should be seven now and
of course night eh form and this is
simply annoying to face the light
appearing on f5 still I would consider
now to play g6 from better worse you
need to do this cannot allow the night
them of course it makes a strange
impression do have this g6 move combined
with the Bishop e7 but it's still better
than allowing not f5 in the game you
played night back to g8 and after night
f5 Bishop f6 so sort of trying to
correct this this g6 Bishop g7 levels
miss perform but I mean not gh cannot be
so great so wyd certainly a.m. enjoys a
nice position here um he played now
night too
no.22 sorry em I saw this wrong applet
22m completing development and 97 so on
what should why do now yes the not only
five which is a very nice piece but how
do you proceed him I think the general
dare to 2m ways to to do this the one
that that William plate here he just
retreated night and this is some very
useful concept if you've got an
advantage in space and white will have
an advantage in space after he pushes at
form then it's a very often a good idea
to keep pieces on the board so that
black is sort of yeah tied up in this
position which has less space so 93 is a
good move another interesting idea would
have been to immediately push a form
trying to get going here quickly and
because like black taking on f5 would
lead to a very nice position with white
having the the bishops exchange and then
we've got 95 coming so black cannot
really take on f5 and then it's annoying
if you cannot take on f5 what move are
you going to play an example line would
be cancelled and take on e5 and yeah
what should like do now possibly this
but so here White has an interesting
possibility this exchange sec and here
why it has a very very nice compensation
for his first exchange he's got them
this target on on the f are very weak
porn and super annoying night you cannot
play rook g8 and white is got them
various ideas to threaten the position
even bishop age 32 f 54 maybe night
Knight to f5 and
it's simply a position where rooks are
not worth much blacks troops are not
doing much and white has got all the
ideas so this would have been also
interesting but then as mentioned the
move from one play 293 is also fine
keeping the pieces on the board yeah and
now I'm the next move it's really
puzzling black plate Knight to c6 now
and allowing 95 here with with the tempo
seems really weird to me I think I'm
like just needed to cancel and try to
survive this this is this position
certainly am is slightly better for
white but it's it's not too terrible leg
might even consider something like this
so I mean black should just castle it's
also questioned if after option on this
after castles what if I should play a
form you have got plenty of time to
improve your position you could also
consider other moves first like a king
h1 and then F 4 and so on so I'm lots of
possibilities but like now played this
some word we had moved 96 and we see
immediately what's happening white can
now use the tc39 to go to d5 with the
tempo yeah blacks queen needs to move
and he went to v8 he could have also
gone to d8 but what are you doing after
nine f5 just terrible to have those two
night seven at your doorstep there
between black gum in order to protect
the deep one he need insulate this move
and then after have for whiter sir it's
just an overwhelming position terrible
terrible I didn't understand what what
he was thinking allowing 95
okay what you want to be eight and now
I'm a very strong move Bishop h3r also
very typical to use this bishop on this
diagonal and the problem is simply white
threatens to take and yeah we're not
cereal with 96 to come so black gum
there's nothing move just just to show
it I could just write can just take try
and grab grab everything here so this is
a huge threat at the anti plate bishops
eh but this some leads to UM
strategically gothic lost position I
mean with good technical play white
should win after this so and he did a
good job here we should be seven from
Knight to f6 I mean it's not them it's
not so nice to trade this brilliant f5
night against the bishop but you need to
look at this position in in concrete
terms this new knight on d5 just the
text f6 and how should black gum protect
the spawn if you consider Queen here
then there's lost just this move and
black and yeah black and resign really
this falls and white has a huge attack
it's just oops no not yet let's say
let's say we should move something like
this and like just um God's just gets
destroyed here the king porn down and
everything just just terrible so I
played we should be six and yeah
surrendered this point immediately it
wasn't possible to keep it takes here
and now f5f form also nice you want to
have to look into play and pry open the
diagonal
possible yeah and this is also a good
move gaining more space there was more
than one way to do this but but I like
this idea because it allows this lie to
come back to d5 at some point and you
now got a position here with those
pieces on the on the kingside this night
is just so nicely placed there it
prevents anything going on the G file at
the text the a7 porn so very very nice
here one plate Bishop d3 very sensible
move the idea being before opening the
queenside in fact here wyd also could
have tried something more forceful but I
fully understand that he didn't do this
I mean here it's even possible to to
play a very aggressive move like before
I just want to show the motif here if
you like takes them with a night then
there's default and this is very
instructive distracting the light from
c6 and now it's possible to play this
tea for you cannot take here because the
light hangs and after each takes d4 just
wish it takes d4 will ensure that all
kinds of lines are opened wide threatens
c5 Group B 1 it's terrible all gets open
to him so this is a bit quicker but it's
not not necessary really you just can
prepare all this with Bishop c3 i just
want to show the IDM no I deform and now
before opening up the queenside like has
got absolutely no counter play Bishop c6
yeah now a simple continuation just swap
the snide
and what's left is this night dominating
the whole board yeah the whole board on
the right sides are the same Paula King
side and this is just this very stupid
bishop yeah and blacks Kingdom white
will just pile up on the queenside
course now the night is saying that you
can just drop back because some yeah
black also cannot really take something
like this to simply won't survive white
will enter on the C file and you've got
an extra porn and so on it's just too
much so we need to move the king and
queen age six is also good attacking d6
intending maybe Queen g7 yeah this is
the last configuration here ya hear this
some position um white can do can do
many things you can also move the Queen
but it's also very simple just
exchanging the Queen which William did
hear it so that this night is dominating
is our local King side and you still
have an attack even if it even with
Queens off just a for ya h5 what what
should like do and b5 attacking the the
bishop on c6 and yeah forcing further
opening of lines of the coincide he
retreated and now it's a very nice
finish taking on a six and now a five
which really opens up the coincide yeah
what should like do in the game here he
captured this porn but alternatives are
not really better let's say move like b5
white can also simply take here I know
you don't like to take it but it's
simply winning if black new Maori
captures you've got shocked this needle
idea and it's made next move so you
catch the King Nia offside on the on the
queenside so yeah often you need to
consider those moves that look quite
awful on general terms but if they are
just straight winning technically it
doesn't matter so b5 wouldn't wouldn't
have saved like I mean there is no way
to save it it took on a five and now
just this controlling the be far and I
mean this is this Bishop is so it's just
stale mate it almost it cannot move
anywhere the only squared can take your
so you see six and which this is also
what he played but now 95 is nice white
now threatens 97 so let's say like would
play something like this you've got them
this coming out or the maid so after 95
this threat is Sir yeah strongest an
understatement so what should like do he
decided to have to take the night and
now yeah white can made into moves and
quite nicely displayed rugby five here
and the next move will be yeah rook
takes a five mate so some new friend
it's rook takes a final check mate yeah
very nice game the black really am had
some problems and handling the opening
the soul set up here sort of implies
that you need to be cautious about your
light squares
and he didn't really pay any attention
to this surprisingly so it's this kind
of setup with Bishop e7 really doesn't
fit so well in this you just should
really take the chance to play g6 Bishop
g7 this is better and here white had the
more comfortable position but 96 just
gave the game away I think it's very
good move all right I hope you enjoyed
the game it showed that you can really
get nice attacking positions also with
close to openings very often those are
really underestimated in a way in terms
of yeah fighting possibilities i also
like to play those some kind of setup as
setups as violent have very nice
successes really even even with nice
attacking games here and there yeah i
would also think about checking this
channel crumble steward online chess
lessons you also get them a link in the
video so also in the description make
sure to check it out it's very very nice
channel and can be a nice addition to
your list of subscriptions on YouTube
thanks for watching and talk to you soon
with new videos